we're talking a lot about west ham and
their player uh in question just there
you can see kurt zuma um the rspca have
taken his cats off him after a video
emerged of him abusing them the fine
imposed by the club quarter of a million
pounds and we've just heard that uh
vitality is suspending its sponsorship
of west ham football club as a result uh
the organization saying we are very
distressed by the video we have seen of
kurt zuma and vitalis at vitality we
condemn animal cruelty and violence of
any kind
vitality is a provider of health
insurance life insurance car insurance
and investments they go on to stay in
the statement we are hugely disappointed
by the judgment subsequently shown by
the club in response to this incident as
such we are suspending our sponsorship
of west ham united with immediate effect
we will now be further engaging with the
club to understand what actions they
will be taking to address the situation
and we've also had this in from heineken
another of west ham sponsors heineken uk
they have a beer inside a partnership
with a club saying we have a
long-standing relationship with west ham
united and like them we are appalled at
the contents of the video any form of
cruelty towards animals is totally
unacceptable and we welcome the actions
west ham are taking um so vitality
suspending its sponsorship of west ham
heineken not going that far uh but
issuing that statement uh saying that
they backed the club with their action
so far of course the club coming in for
criticism for playing kurt zuma in their
match against watford last night the
player roundly booed at west ham's home
ground chance of rspca
the rspca are
carrying out an investigation as we
speak they've taken the cats into their
care and the player has received a fine
of two weeks wages we understand 250 000
pounds which he and the club are
donating to animal welfare charities